Transcriptor: Javier Ignacio Moyano
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
¿Alguna vez se preguntaron
cuánto tiempo de su vida pasan
yendo y viniendo a la oficina?
Me puse a hacer la cuenta
si viven a 30 minutos de su oficina
y trabajan de los 20 a los 60 años,
más o menos 40 años,
son 13 meses de su vida
que pierden yendo y viniendo
de la oficina.
Trece meses.
Si viven a 60 minutos de la oficina
son dos años.
Es increíble.
¿Por qué vamos a una oficina?,
me empecé a preguntar.
¿Por qué solamente contrato en la
región donde tengo una oficina?
Si nos remontamos un poco
más atrás en el tiempo,
vemos, que durante
la Revolución Industrial,
hace 500 años,
las personas se empiezan a mudar
del campo a las ciudades
porque ahí están las fábricas.
Ahí hay trabajo.
Pero no estamos más en esa época,
las cosas cambiaron.
Pero seguimos teniendo ciudades
enormes en el mundo,
que siguen creciendo.
Hay más de 50 áreas urbanas en el mundo
con más de diez millones de personas.
No dejamos de ir a las ciudades
porque ahí hay trabajo.
Pero la tecnología ya cambió.
Ahora tenemos celulares,
tenemos internet, tenemos email.
Tenemos Microsoft Excel.
Imagínense cómo hacía la gente
para trabajar sin Excel.
No cambiamos la forma de trabajar,
seguimos haciendo lo mismo
que hacíamos hace mucho tiempo.
Y creo que en esta nueva era,
la era de la globalización,
deberíamos empezar a replantearnos
cómo trabajamos y estas cosas básicas
de si tenemos que ir a algún lugar.
Hace cinco años logré algo
por primera vez en mi vida
que me costó mucho trabajo
y mucho esfuerzo.
En julio del año 2014
pude ver todos los partidos
del mundial de Brasil
desde el sillón de mi casa.
(Risas)
No es fácil, son 64 partidos.
Esto requiere mucho esfuerzo
Pero la razón por la que pude hacer esto
es que ese mismo año
empecé a trabajar de forma remota
para una empresa.
Era una empresa de diez personas
donde uno de los fundadores
era argentino que vivía en Buenos Aires,
el otro argentino en Estados Unidos.
El primer empleado era de Córdoba
y esto de trabajar remoto
se dio naturalmente.
¿Qué es trabajar remoto?
Es poder trabajar desde dónde
uno se siente cómodo.
Puede ser
de la casa,
puede ser
de un café,
puede ser de una oficina
si la hay,
puede ser de otro país,
en un parque, lo que a uno le guste.
La capacidad de poder hacer su trabajo
no depende de dónde uno está.
Y acá quizás muchos están pensando
qué hace este millennial en el escenario
viniendo a cambiar lo que hacemos
hace un muchos de años;
no quieren ni siquiera trabajar;
no quieren ir al trabajo.
Esto no funciona, claramente.
Eran diez personas,
solamente funciona sin son pocos.
¿Cómo me aseguro de que la gente
no está en su casa mirando Intrusos
en vez de estar trabajando?
Por suerte, en esta empresa
y muchas otras donde se trabaja así,
trabajamos mucho.
Y logramos crecer bastante.
Hoy, esta es una empresa
que tiene 500 personas
en 30 países.
Vale más de mil millones de dólares.
Es el quinto "unicornio" argentino,
empresas que valen más
de mil millones de dólares.
Se llama: "Auth0"
Lo interesante, es que podemos pensar
"Bueno, esta es una excepción",
"Un caso que funciona no quiere decir
que esto funcione".
Lo que empezamos a ver es
que están apareciendo más
de estas empresas.
Hay otras tres empresas que llegaron
a esta valuación de mil millones
y ni siquiera tienen oficinas.
No hay dónde ir a trabajar
si uno quisiera.
Entonces,empezamos a ver que
la tecnología ya está permitiendo
que nosotros podamos hacer esto.
No hay impedimentos, podemos
llegar a números grandes.
Mil millones de dólares no es poco.
Quinientas personas no es poco.
Si bajamos también a lo más cotidiano
porque estas empresas quizás
son cosas a la que
no estamos acostumbrados,
vemos que esto está empezando a pasar
en otros trabajos que quizás
no nos hubiéramos preguntado
antes si podía ser.
Un ejemplo muy interesante
es el caso de un amigo mío.
Es contador.
En el año 2014 se lesionó una pierna.
No pudo ir a trabajar por un mes.
No podía ir.
Se pidió una licencia
y trabajó desde la casa.
Quizás miró algún partido del mundial.
(Risas)
Pero, ese mes pudo trabajar perfectamente.
Llamaba a sus compañeros de trabajo,
a sus clientes por teléfono,
se conectaba a la red de la empresa
para usar nuestro tan querido
Microsoft Excel.
Y pudo hacer su trabajo de forma normal.
Trabajó bien.
El problema es que terminó ese mes
y tuvo que volver a la oficina.
Ponerse camisa, pantalón de vestir,
saco, maletín y siguió haciendo lo mismo.
Otro caso muy interesante
es un caso de otro amigo mío
que tiene al psicólogo por Skype.
Es normal ya, pero hace eso
él vive acá,
el psicólogo vive en Miami
y se comunican así.
Imagínense algo tan íntimo
como es la relación con el psicólogo
y poder hacerlo de forma remota.
Y otro ejemplo muy interesante
del área de la salud
es lo que hacen las empresas
de medicina prepaga, hoy por hoy.
A mi esposa le dolía la garganta,
llamamos un médico
para que venga a la casa.
Nos dijeron, sí, ahora lo mandamos
pero si quieren, antes,
podemos hacer una sesión con un médico
por videollamada para revisar a su esposa.
Obviamente, dije que no.
¿Cómo van a revisarle la garganta
a una persona con una cámara?
No se ve nada.
Véanlo si lo probaron alguna vez.
¿Qué hago con la receta?
En la farmacia le voy a dar una receta
que me la habrán enviado por mail.
Obviamente, falsa.
Entonces, hay muchas cosas que todavía
hay que limar los detalles.
Pero vean como las empresas de
medicina prepaga buscan bajar sus costos,
no tener que enviar un médico
a la casa de todas las personas
que lo necesiten.
Y al mismo tiempo poder dar
una mejor atención al cliente.
Llegar más rápido
No tener que esperar dos horas que
siempre tarda el médico en llegar a casa.
Lo que quizás en diez minutos
podemos recibir una respuesta.
Entonces,
si nos ponemos a pensar
el trabajo remoto está apareciendo,
ya está, es el presente,
y la pregunta pasa a ser:
¿Por qué no sucede más?
¿Por qué no lo estamos haciendo más?
Y la respuesta es que
faltan culturas de confianza.
No se confía en que si la persona
no está ahí,
va a estar trabajando,
es así.
Pensamos que el empleado modelo
es aquella persona que trabaja
de 9 a 18,
viene vestida de una forma particular
a la oficina,
llega puntual, se va puntual,
hace sus tareas.
El modelo del jefe
es el modelo del jefe que controla.
El jefe es controla que
la persona esté trabajando.
¿Cómo controlo a alguien que no puedo ver?
Es imposible.
Ahora, pensemos un segundo esto.
Las grandes empresas, todas
esas cosas de las reuniones.
La gente va vestida
de una forma particular.
Vestida de traje.
No confían en que vayas a vestirte bien.
Y te dicen que te debes poner.
Encima son todos iguales,
imagínense si va a confiar en que
cuando no nos estén mirando,
uno esté trabajando.
Obvio que no.
Ahora, si empezamos a confiar
si vemos la forma de confiar,
abrimos un abanico muy interesante
de posibilidades.
Como empresa puedo ahorrar dinero
porque no tengo que tener oficinas grandes
puedo contratar en una mayor cantidad
de lugares,
no estoy restringido
a que la gente deba tener
un lugar físico
media hora o una hora de su casa
para poder ir a trabajar.
Y al mismo tiempo, algo muy interesante,
retengo más a la gente,
la gente está más contenta
por no deber ir a la oficina.
La gente podrá viajar menos,
estará menos cansada,
probablemente produzca un poco más.
Entonces, se abren un par
de beneficios muy interesantes.
Y desde el punto de vista de la persona
que trabaja en la empresa
pasa lo mismo para el otro lado.
Podemos trabajar desde donde queremos,
en muchos casos podemos trabajar
con un horario flexible.
Podemos trabajar en una cultura
que tiene esta confianza como base,
esto es muy importante,
trabajar en un ambiente
donde la gente confía en mí,
en que yo estoy haciendo mi tarea,
que podemos colaborar bien
es muy valioso,
mejora tu calidad de vida
trabajar en un ambiente así.
Finalmente, para derribar un poco mitos,
hace poco salió un estudio de la Escuela
de Negocios de Harvard que dice:
La misma gente trabajando desde la casa
que trabajando desde la oficina,
es más productiva desde la casa.
Y esa misma gente
trabajando de forma remota,
de la casa o cualquier otro lado,
comparado con trabajar desde la casa
es más productiva de forma remota.
El mito de que si la persona
no está no va a producir
es mentira.
Está demostrado.
Hay estudios que lo demuestran
Ahora, cambia la pregunta.
Esto sabemos que funciona.
¿Cómo hacemos para hacerlo?
Lo que nosotros hacemos en Auth0
empieza por cómo contratamos.
Esto es lo más importante.
Además de hacer entrevistas a la gente
lo que hacemos es,
le mandamos un ejercicio,
como una "tarea" para el hogar.
Ahí vemos si la gente está cómoda
trabajando de forma remota.
No es para todos.
Y también vemos si nosotros estamos
cómodos con las personas.
Especialmente, una cosa que miramos mucho
es el tema de la comunicación.
¿Se pueden comunicar bien?
¿Se nos entiende al hablar
por email o por un chat?
Porque esto que estamos teniendo nosotros
ahora que me están viendo,
que yo estoy haciendo
movimientos con las manos,
que están escuchándome
con un tono de vos distinto,
no está cuando trabajamos
de forma remota, en muchos casos.
Que haya gente que se comunique bien
es fundamental para este tipo de trabajos.
La contrapartida de eso
es la transparencia.
Si nosotros podemos ser transparentes,
mantener la información disponible,
hacer que la gente pueda acceder
a la información, que tiene
que poder acceder y no cerrarla,
la gente podrá obtener el contexto
para hacer su trabajo.
Si nosotros hacemos que
las cosas necesiten permisos,
que siempre haya que preguntar,
si no hay material para consultar
es muy difícil aprender o conseguir
el contexto para trabajar.
Y a diferencia de lo que mencionamos antes
el rol de los jefes deja de ser controlar,
pasa a ser trasmitir ese contexto:
Para dónde vamos y por qué queremos ir.
Del lado de la gente que entra
es muy importante la autonomía.
Puede ser que uno trate de hablar
con alguien que no está
en su zona horaria.
Puede ser que trate de hablar con alguien
que no está en ese momento
y necesito una respuesta.
Entonces poder resolver,
tener esa autonomía, esa capacidad,
es muy importante.
Finalmente, no es que nosotros decimos que
el contacto "cara a cara" o las relaciones
no sirven.
Todo lo contrario,
el tema es, ser remotos es lo que hacemos.
El trabajo remoto
para nosotros es trabajo.
Pero, una vez por año,
todas las personas de la empresa,
hoy 500,
nos juntamos en algún lugar del mundo
y nos volvemos a conocer.
Ver como esa persona
utiliza sus gestos,
ese tono de voz,
quizás esa frase particular.
Podemos entablar esa relación
para que la próxima vez que pidan algo
lo voy a tomar de otra forma
y es muy interesante
cómo se da esa diferencia.
Me pasó unas veces,
entraba gente a la empresa,
no la conocía y me pedían algo por chat.
Era raro a veces, depende las palabras,
depende de lo que uno está acostumbrado.
Pero cuando uno la conocía en persona,
esa misma línea
se lee completamente de otra forma.
Hacemos esto mismo
a parte de todos,
por equipo.
Entonces todos lo equipos
una vez por año se juntan
y hacen exactamente lo mismo
pero a menor escala,
quizás entre seis y diez personas.
Yo les estoy contando todo esto
pero no quiero que vayan hoy mismo
o el lunes
y planteen querer digitalizar todo,
quiero cambiar mi trabajo,
tampoco quiero que se pasen
directamente a la industria informática.
Quiero desafiarlos a pensar
cómo van a hacer para crear
estas culturas de confianza
en donde Uds. trabajan.
Cómo van a hacer para trabajar un poco más
de forma remota.
Y qué van a hacer
con el tiempo que dejarán de perder
en horas de viaje.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)